So as we get closer and closer to Election
Day, there are, not surprisingly, some numbers
that are not giving me a high level of confidence
that I know some in my audience already have
about the seemingly inevitable pending victory
of Joseph R. Biden.
Junior now.
I already told you last week that as of about
twenty two days out in three key states, Michigan,
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania, Hillary Clinton
had a bigger lead in 2016 than Joe Biden had
last week.
We will update update those numbers this week.
But it was a cause for maybe not concern,
but at least for being very, very cautious.
There is another signal that given the realities
of the election, is not a great signal for
Joe Biden.
And this is both voter registrations in some
states and mail in ballot requests and even
early voting numbers in some states.
And remember why?
Why are we analyzing it in this way?
Because this is an Electoral College election.
The first candidate to get to 200.
The only candidate to get to 270 electoral
votes wins overall, new voter registrations.
And early voting and mail in ballots don't
matter.
It matters in states that would make a difference
if Democrats have registered way more new
voters in California.
Great.
But Joe Biden's going to win California.
It's not going to move the needle and get
Joe Biden any more electoral votes.
Likewise, if we assume that early voting will
be skewed towards Biden.
But Republicans ask for more mail in ballots.
That would be a red flag.
And in the states, that could be key.
There are some numbers that look good for
Trump.
So let me give you a couple of examples.
Despite Michigan polling having Joe Biden
seven points ahead in terms of mail in ballots
requested in Michigan, Republicans have requested
more mail in ballots than Democrats in Michigan.
So remember, we were expecting mail in ballots
to be overwhelmingly Biden voters.
Biden is plus seven in Michigan polling.
And yet, forty one to thirty nine Republicans
have requested more mail in ballots.
And in total, if you combine mail in ballot
requests plus early votes, Republicans have
voted more than Democrats in Michigan.
That's not a number that I look at and say,
great.
Joe Biden's got Michigan in the bag.
Similarly, if we look at the state of Wisconsin,
which is a very important state, ended up
being extraordinarily important in 2016, despite
Joe Biden leading the polls by six in Wisconsin,
Republicans in Wisconsin have requested more
mail in ballots by 40 to 38.
A small margin if you include mail in plus
early voting.
Republicans are down only 38 to 40.
And again, Biden supposedly is winning by
six there.
We expect Biden would win the Maylin vote,
but that Trump would win the in-person vote
on November 3rd.
What we are seeing so far does not correspond
with the expectations based on polling and
preferences about voting by mail versus voting
in person.
These are not good numbers.
Now, in some other states, things look fine.
Pennsylvania, for example, which is looking
like it's going to be a key state.
The numbers in Pennsylvania are very skewed
in favor of Democrats.
Democrats requesting way more mail in ballots.
Democrats voting early by a huge majority
in Pennsylvania, like 65 to 25.
Major margin doesn't mean it's over.
But the point is, Pennsylvania is looking
much better based on what we expected relative
to Wisconsin and Michigan.
The point here is we are, what, 15 days out?
There is no sense in taking any chances, given
the numbers that we are seeing so far.
You can find a way to make the numbers look
just great for Joe Biden.
Just leave it alone.
Biden is winning today in the popular vote
by more than Hillary was on Election Day 2016.
But that's not the way that this election
will be decided when you compare.
Fifteen days out to fifteen days out, the
numbers change.
When you look at registrations, which I want
to do, the numbers don't look quite so good.
Let's briefly talk about that.
Republicans have registered more voters than
Democrats since the primary elections this
year in the states of Florida, North Carolina
and Pennsylvania.
That's not good.
It's very difficult to extrapolate that one
number to the results we would get on November
3rd.
But it is cause for, if not concern, it is
cause for very much caution.
I voted on Saturday.
I published a video of me voting to my Instagram.
I used a real ballot drop box.
I think I got about 150 messages from people
saying, David, that doesn't look like a postal
service mailbox.
It's because it's not.
I used an official city of Boston registered,
clearly delineated well-known Dropbox at at
a state building.
It's a real Dropbox.
I didn't mail my ballot.
I dropped it off.
I haven't been tricked.
It's okay.
Let's all do it.
Let me know, of course, about any irregularities
that you experience or any trouble whatsoever
that you run into.